the game grumps that I I them to death
and I love being able to with them on a
regular basis it's hard salty with deke
pika did I ever tell you guys about the
time that I broke my cuz that was an
interesting experience I will admit I
fell and shattered my in both bones so
when I stood up my was like a it was
like this weird staircase step like mark
you should try getting in the business
the world needs to see more of your
videos oh my goodness
tell a romantic story about a dog in a
cactus no the dog the cactus the dog
said oh that gave me shivers but once
again I have the same question of why
the hell were there scratches on the
inside of my little ear literally you
Photoshop a eunuch own and have a really
big head Lowell love you mark okay I
guess cool no more people would react
very hard
mister I actually had a fan that did a
running tackle at me while I was doing a
signing and she nearly cracked my neck
was broken at this point and it didn't
hurt it didn't hurt at all which was
very bizarre right up until the point
where I decided to set it myself
because it was it didn't hurt and my was
a staircase and obviously that's not
right so in my mind I was like I need to
fix this so I grabbed it by it's broken
part and just squeeze really tightly a
good friend from angry you up on the lip
adores how do I talk in the lip doors
are to be abandoned immediate right it's
stupid to try to set your own even
though the doctor when he saw my broken
said I had it almost correctly you know
he went up to me and he was like oh you
know you almost did a great job here you
almost had it perfectly and then he
grabbed my reset the bone snapping it in
Twain and causing an immense amount of
pain so that was the time that I broke
my